foreign
number one benefit that I believe is the
flexibility I always wanted to do an MBA
but the whole commute and other things
was a little difficult for me and when
these on-demand courses actually came
when I was doing some research I felt
like the time commitment was shot it fit
with my schedule really well and I was
able to learn something new while not
slowing down on other aspects of my life
format of the course is very Hands-On
it's very practical it's very structured
simple to apply the benefit s of this
course that I could
I could with which I'm thinking about
the problem the business the competition
I'm definitely seeing myself apply
whatever I learned on a day-to-day basis
and it was structured in such a way that
you've got to apply a lot of thinking
and that was a fun part every
participant gets their assignments that
they have to submit they get the
feedback facilitators there is some
reflection with them
I was looking for some guidance
Frameworks thinking support in that area
so that we can disrupt our own business
the Stanford course enabled me to look
from an outsider point of view on my own
business and it enabled me to identify
growth and optimization that has been
super beneficial to the leadership team
of my company if you want to learn
something these individual courses are
definitely changing the way one can
operate I would say just don't wait just
take it
[Music]